comment vous avez accueilli anna comment
ça s'est passé on a bon je la connais
depuis un peu plus d'un an c'est l'ami
d'un ami adacore classé l'ami d'un ami
donc bon parler de reconversion
professionnelle de choses comme ça parce
que je travaille dans l'informatique
qu'elle voulait donner devenir
développeuse donc on en a parlé comme ça
et puis derrière une relation s'est crée
donc une relation virtuelle bien sûr
revient sur la distance bien entendu et
puis
deux jours avant que que la guerre
éclate en plaisanter sur deux choses et
d'autres ont parlé de choses et d'autres
ont plaisanté et puis ça s'est passé
elle a décidé très rapidement de partir
mais ne savait pas où aller exactement
parce que j'étais complètement perdu et
son histoire c'est ça exactement
l'histoire de de tous les gens qui ont
fui la paix leur pays ces derniers jours
on a près de 3 millions quand même
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui en pologne après
la frontière polonaise et moi j'essayais
simplement d'abord de la sécuriser c'est
à dire de lui donner un objectif un but
parce que je savais pas du tout où aller
et de lui dire viens à marseille à une
maison qui t'attend d'accord qui ton ami
je viens avec ta fille vous êtes en
sécurité voilà j'ai même utilisé le fait
que la france souhaite une puissance
nucléaire pour être pour lui pour la
rassurer on a une armée t'inquiète pas
voilà donc donc elle a mis plusieurs
jours à venir à l'adie déjà mis trois
jours pour traverser son pays sur la
filiale saab la ville de périès lave qui
est au sud de leclerc elle n'a plus
aucune famille là-bas assiste ici à la
sa maman elle à sa grand mère à qui il
ya aussi tous ses amis à huy sont là bas
bien sûr ça fait du monde elle est
toujours en lien avec ça et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'elle était choquée par ce par
ce qui s'est passé hier
sur les réseaux sociaux et donc moi j'ai
dansé régulière on va on va dire sans
reparler après même pas la peine d'en
parler après il faudrait je voudrais
d'abord gagne pas le voile c'est
important de voilà pourquoi vous l'a
vécu moi j'ai accueilli pour ça au
départ et puis ensuite on s'est très
rapidement avec deux amis marina luca
sheva qui est ukrainienne et qui vit à
marseille depuis neuf ans quitte
architectes là bas et mon ami fabien vie
qui est chef cuisinier on s'est très
vite dit que ce que moi j'étais en train
de faire pour elle il fallait faire pour
d'autres et donc on a décidé de créer
cette association donc sur le hyaric
rennes marseille france qui en fait un
objectif très simple ces ralliés des
hébergeurs potentiel mais pour proposer
des hébergements d'urgence voilà
aujourd'hui à organiser les choses en
fait exactement à aujourd'hui on a plus
de 120 familles sur marseille qui est
qui qui qui se sont portés volontaires
et ça nous fait à peu près 375 places
d'hébergement pour des réfugiés
donc à venir ou déjà là alors anna est
arrivé depuis plus puis combien de temps
maintenant à la maison depuis 3 mars
donc ça fait une grosse quinzaine de
jours exactement là où je passe bien
tout se passe bien c'est fait avec
saphir et graphiques à cinq ans et voilà
qu'il ya cinq ans qui est maintenant
scolarisés voilà ça c'est un vrai
objectif c'était la première chose dont
on s'était dit c'est d'abord la fille
qu'elle soit en sécurité qu'elles
puissent avoir éventuellement une des
perspectives parce que on ne sait pas
combien de temps ça va durer voilà c'est
ça c'est l'inconnue de la guerre donc on
nous on a décidé de tout de suite se
battre pour que la petite fille soit à
l'école et rapidement vous habitez tout
seul chez vous mais moi je suis sûr que
je suis dit on n'est pas devant voilà
non non non chaque ruelle j'ai de la
place bon là c'est une nouvelle maison à
laquelle je suis encore en travaux donc
d'accord je vais accueillir une personne
d'ici deux jours nos répertoires une
autre ukrainienne voilà des arrivées qui
est une
cousine dana doit arriver par la route
donc et pour laquelle je suis en train
de sécuriser le voyage via la slovénie
puis l'italie chez des badauds revenir
chez des amis à moi un peu partout voilà
pour pour arriver tranquillement après
mai et puis c'est que vous ayez dû
rassurer je pensais à ça anna sur la
france sur du rap long on avait les
armes nucléaires c'est un truc de fou ça
nous paraît incroyable ça nous paraît
tellement loin nous mais la base c'est
une guerre on assure alain guihard il ya
une bo des bombes qui tombent et c'est
donc y aller jouer demi tour
pour tous ses proches pour tous les
longs puisque pour tous les ukrainiens
voilà qui vivent qu'ils vivent l'enfer
alors anna
anna l'air extrêmement touchée
extrêmement voilà et c'est dans malin
comme commence vous êtes heureuse d'être
d'être chez olivier olivier vous à un
petit peu sauvé la vie hein c'est vrai à
vous et votre fille
d'avoir été accueilli par l'envié
reconnaissant qu' on est jetés sociaux
avant tout de la sécurité de ma fille
c'est ça là c'est le plus important est
très reconnaissant en plus maintenant on
sait qu'elle est scolarisé donc c'est
ccva bravo olivier alors il ya il ya
cette polémique qui nous a rendu fou ici
il ya une ans et moins de temps sur les
réseaux sociaux vous l'avez vu gilles
est ce que pouvaient expliquer aux
téléspectateurs la polémique qui a eu
sur olivier en gros on a dit qu olivier
accueilli à une jeune femme
parce que c'était une jeune femme et
pour des motifs potentiellement
inavouables la polémique est scandaleux
et si on se dit les mots vraiment c'est
sa naissance et dix comme par hasard ils
accueillent une jeune femme
extraordinairement belle et voilà donc
on vous a reproché en gros de choisir
une réfugiée que vous auriez accueilli
parce qu'elle était belle voilà dit
crûment mais c'est ça met crûment alors
crûment je vais répondre présent je
confirme que je les choisis puisque
c'était mon ami auparavant donc geforce
et ça c'est cool c'est une information
importante et vous la connaissez oui je
la connaissais d'avant donc voilà donc
ça fait plus d'un an que je dis qu'on
parle qu'on verse donc je la connaissais
avant donc c'est une amie c'est l'ami
d'un ami d'un joueur de rugby semi
professionnel qui vit dans le sud de la
france qui est ukrainien il avait
présenté donc comme ça pour les raisons
que je vous ai expliqué tout à l'heure
et donc c'est d'abord elle que j'ai
voulu sécuriser et ensuite je vous dis
on a on a monté cette association pour
justement de faire la même chose avec
les autres et bien évidemment on ne
regarde pas le physique voilà c'est
évidemment c'est évident il se trouve
que ce sont essentiellement des femmes
avec des enfants puisque les hommes sont
des conscrits sont censés se battre on
va passer les frontières donc un mec
comme tout le monde a dit cana était
célibataire aussi basket voilà elle est
séparée de son mari voilà les gens sont
imaginés oui béatrice puisque je vous
voyais
sur la polémique où nous reçoit
polémique
bon la polémique est un peu ridicule le
principal c'est que sa fille soit
scolarisé c'est qu'elle soit hors de
danger je trouve ça assez loi que
surtout si vous allez accueillir
d'autres personnes dans votre maison
parce que vous avez de la place
franchement il n'ya là rien d'autre qui
vient ou genton vous qui avez vu tout ce
qui traînait sur les noms mais là est la
question qu on a envie de vous poser est
ce que vous auriez accueilli un homme de
votre âge par exemple alors la question
je réponds encore une fois j'ai eu la
même chose c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai
fait ça au départ parce que je la
connaissais ça veut dire qu'en fait ma
réponse et je ne sais pas si je vais
très non je sais pas mais après
effectivement que la journée quand même
investi parce que c'est une guerre et
que c'est qu'elle est à nos portes pour
moi c'est marseille brest la distance on
jamais main en terme de kilométrage
c'est pareil donc pour moi c'est à côté
bon donc je n'aurai probablement avec
mon caractère je ne serais probablement
investi dans une association de ce type
de la halle a cofondé je peux pas vous
dire car cela j'étais effectivement
intéressés par le fait que je connais
anna depuis longtemps j'étais donc au
téléphone avec elle pendant qu'elle
voyage et j'étais au contact permanent
si vous voulez parce que pour info pour
bien raconter les choses donc il ya 750
km entre sa ville d'origine et la
frontière polonaise elle a mis trois
jours et demi pour l'atteindre et les
dix derniers kilomètres on était en
ligne on était ensemble au téléphone
avec sa petite fille ne pouvait pas
garder sa voiture la voiture avec
laquelle il était arrivé parce que ça la
frontière problème si laisse pas passer
les voitures d'accord donc c'était 10 km
en 8 heures dans la neige le froid avec
deux valises à une gamine mais la
question que les gens se posent c'est
est ce que vous êtes intéressés par le
fait que c'était aussi une très jolie
femme que vous connaissez et célibataire
me mets dans mes shows je vous redis et
je le dis très simplement mon célibat
dacourt a posé la question
il répond j'ai mon célibat d'abord y est
ça dépend des jours ça dépend des nuits
voilà
ça c'est ma vie perso voilà donc je pas
j'ai pas forcément à l'étalé non je dis
simplement c'est pas une question alors
de quoi avoir une part d'ombré favorable
pour avoir une visage balafré c'est mon
ami j'ai pas que des amis qui sont juste
belle c'est pas la question voilà mais
avec des informaticiens match par les
informations non mai déjà alors je crois
monsieur de bonne foi après je vous dire
quand bien même oui j'aime bien quand
bien même il l'aurait choisie parce
qu'elle est jolie il se trouve qu'il
l'aurait sauvé une femme et un enfant
d'un pays en guerre il est toujours des
connards dans ce pays ça me fait penser
aux restos du coeur pour tony va pour
faire parler de lui en attendant il a
fait une légende et jean oui alors peu
importe la raison ces systèmes non mais
là là votre exemple il est nul oui
mathieu on a un blessé mathieu on avait
six jeunes qu'on arrête de m'appeler du
tri des réfugiés ou parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont choisis parce qu'ils sont
noirs parce qu'ils sont blancs parce
qu'ils sont chrétiens parce qu'ils sont
pas chrétiens c'est aussi pardon mais
c'est aussi dégueulasse de choisir une
jeune femme est derrière plein de
blagues sur sa avant vous incarnez
maison du genre qui vous résistent
personnes sur tout et qui ne suis allé
moi je me mets à la place des gens qui
sont des hommes qui sont plus âgés qui
sont pas forcément beau fils a
choisi à cause de ça oui on enlevait
n'entend parler d'un début de trafic
bien sûr l'aspect pierre sa jeune femme
est donc et de deux mafieux qui viennent
entre guillemets de alors marcher faire
leur marché sur la détresse humaine et
mentir à ses jeunes femmes à mentir à
des femmes avec leurs enfants pour
justement alimenter des trafics et ça il
faut absolument mettre le point que le
doigt dessus et le dire et faire
attention à ça donc j'ai dit non non on
va l'aider à raison il ya 5000 enfants
quand même qu'ils ont disparu
aujourd'hui des radars mais moi je est
ce que vous voulez faire venir votre
maman par exemple est ce que voulaient
rapatrier la cjue ya une amie avec qui
arrive à ce que nous a dit
je le souhaiterais bien autant dieu mais
elle ne veut pas venir parce que
[Musique]
el fata importante dans une usine un
poste à responsabilités et elle veut
absolument rester à son poste dans
l'intérêt des autres salariés oui j'ai
olivier c'est vrai que la question qui
se pose est que soulève des responsables
d'associations traditionnel c'est de
dire que ces personnes comme anna sont
vulnérables et donc la question c'est
qu'est ce qui va se passer après et moi
je vous la pose très crûment est ce que
il est possible qu'une relation
s'initier entre vous est ce que vous
l'avez fait venir pour sa foi et non
mais valérie faut que vous acquérez
valerio et là il arrive aussi une paire
d'années non mais je lui remets aux
relevés des venu pour ça il ya ceux qui
étaient venus l'arrêter et mis à l'abri
tourner sur france 3 c'est la dignité
il peut y avoir de l'amour mais oui
disent n'importe quoi si vous racontez
la question de la vulnérabilité elle se
pose sur les réseaux on m'a mis sur la
polémique on a on a invité olivier
aujourd'hui pour mettre tout à plat
olivet voulant parler lui a pris comme
ça au moins il y aura plus de polémiques
voilà répondre anna j'aimerais d'abord
savoir l'histoire d'anna parce que c'est
important aussi qu'elle nous raconte son
histoire voilà comment et quelle est
l'histoire d'un là vous faisiez quoi en
ukraine je sais que vous êtes séparé de
votre ex-mari vous avez de votre fille
seule racontez nous
[Musique]
car je vais faire laver ma fille dans ma
ville de tergnier
comme de jardin d'enfants a fermé il a
fait des arrêts de travail pour
m'occuper de ma fille auparavant
travaillé j'étais salarié
et lorsque la guerre ait quitté
il fallait absolument que je fasse nos
valises et que je sauve à toute vitesse
immédiatement c'est olivier que je
quitte le pays si olivier c'est vous qui
lui avait proposé pendant que c'est son
ami qui était un ami elle qui est à
donetsk qui est ukrainien dont qui
aujourd'hui se bat d'accord dans son
pays qui lui a dit on est en train de
voir arriver les premières bombes il
faut que tu aies c'est vous qui lui a
proposé de venir ou celle qui vous ai
dit ce que je peux venir n'a été encore
on était en contact
comme on était en contact ensemble
experts mot sur la route je lui ai dit
je laissais délai de l'aider de la
rassurer sur ne t'inquiète pas ça va
bien se passer arrête toi cette nuit ne
croise pas des tanks des choses comme ça
il fallait pas roulé donc ensuite je lui
ai donné un objectif il est d'ailleurs
une visibilité dire parce que la
problématique c ou est ce qu est ce qu
on va voilà aujourd'hui vous avez donc
quand je disais tout à l'heure trois
millions de personnes qui sont derrière
la frontière polonaise parce qu'ils
espèrent pourra retourner très vite chez
eux bon si on analyse froidement la
situation ça risque de pas arriver comme
ça voilà on sait pas combien de temps va
durer cette guerre on sait pas dans quel
état sera le pays après donc et puis
nous en tant qu'association dis
simplement on essaye de prévost prévenir
de prévoir donc dans le sens prévoir le
fait que la pologne puis à moins de
vivre attendez il ya 3 millions la
france va devoir en prendre un petit peu
voilà alors c'est là dessus qu'on
travaille aux oliviers alors vous êtes
venus ici aujourd'hui parce qu'on a tous
vu la photo et sur les réseaux sociaux
je le redis aux téléspectateurs c'est un
déferlement oui ils accueillent anna
parce que c'est une belle fille voilà
donc et c'est vrai que ce soir olivier
je tiens à le dire il est très courageux
et il voulait il a dit moi je réponds à
toutes les questions je peux mettre fin
à ces polémiques parce qu'olivier il
fait pas du tout ça pour ça et s'il faut
qu'ils accueillent d'autres gens il
accueillera d'autres gens d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il est en train de faire
dans les prochaines semaines mais gilles
allain poser une question que c'est vrai
que c'est la question qui se pose sur
les réseaux sociaux vous pouvez leur
poser à olivier oui olivier autour de la
vulnérabilité de ces femmes seules ou
avec des enfants qui arrivent et on se
tous la question quelle est la réelle
motivation qui vous fait l'accueillir et
les deux vulnérabilités
trouve que là ça c'est pas mon s non
mais c'est pas ça le temps que c'est pas
la question c'est est ce que est ce que
voulait c'était une amie elle c'était
une amie lui sait pas il la connaît pas
de plus je voudrais juste js que vous
espérez policiers une relation avec elle
voilà quel est le vrai but moi je vais
répondre sur la vulnérabilité la
question et directe mais c'est mieux
qu'il n'y a pas eu aucun souci avec sa
fille la bourse à la vulnérabilité
d'abord c'est un sujet c'est le sujet
c'est pas tant la vulnérabilité c'est
qu'elles sont perturbés parce qu'elles
ont reçus parce qu'elles sont croisés
par des images que nous en fait déjà on
n'a pas vu et les images aussi qu'elle
continue de voir sur son téléphone
quotidiennement qui sont envoyées par
des médias de la ba locaux des
photographes et que ça ils sont bien
plus horrible que ce qu'on peut nous
voir je vous dis moi j'en ai vu
certaines bon c'était c'est plus que
trash voilà c'est plus que trash mais
c'est la réalité de cette guerre donc
elles sont pas tellement vulnérable si
je puis dire par rapport à celle que
j'ai rencontré déjà notamment la
préfecture j'ai passé trois jours pour
faire de marseille
elles sont perturbées le moindre bruit
ça devient compliqué la nuit un bon
voilà donc toutes ces choses là existent
elles existent donc sonné dans la
perturbation voilà on est dans le
psychologique la deuxième question donc
qui est est ce que moi j'espère quelque
chose de ça moi je n'espérais simplement
une chose c'était aider une amie lui
donne un objectif à atteindre pour
qu'elle se sente bien aujourd'hui je
pense qu'elle se sent mieux
de là à dire qu'elle se sent bien c'est
pas le cas c'est pas le cas parce
qu'effectivement elle a de la famille
des amis des amis qui se battent etc etc
c'est la guerre je suis à se sentir bien
on ne peut pas baser une de toute façon
enfin je crois pas un moins pas dans mon
monde à moi une relation sur ce genre de
choses c'est impossible il ya un an
vacants agir
oui je voudrais dire quelque chose a
terriblement choquant
c'est vrai que j'ai pas une tête que
réfugiés mais j'en suis sûr
3 millions
enfin merci le long de la frontière des
milliers d'ukrainiens
et dans cinq lignes à
tirer des bombes nous avons
appelé au secours comment appeler à
l'aide
parce que j'ai joué
les photos pierre
j'ai vu que l'on plaisantait à ce sujet
certains commentateurs
permettait
commentaires qu'ils ont faits concernant
l' avantage d'avoir des réfugiés de
jolis réfugiés j'étais terriblement
choqué c'est important que nous lisier
anna parce que vous l'avoir vraiment
votre avis là-dessus olivier vous lire
j'ai rajouté une chose sur ce sur ce
débat là sur cette photo la bande à bord
c'est un screenshot d'une interview
qu'on a donnée pour un journal du matin
donc oui j'avoue je suis pas très bel
homme et là effectivement j'ai eu jean
sales têtes dont l'olivier de pervers et
j'assume j'ai 43 ans avait longtemps
qu'on sait ville derrière moi ya pas
trop et là dessus c'est juste que
moi au départ ça m'a fait sourire on ne
part ça m'a fait sourire c'est quand
j'ai compris derrière ce qu'il y avait
dedans dessous c'est à dire tous ses
jambes envoyée on a alors il ya
effectivement des gens un peu petit peu
connue entre guillemets un petit peu
connu ensuite il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas de vie du tout qui on ne m'aime pas
leurs noms sur les réseaux sociaux quand
même pas leurs photos etc moi j'en veux
je ne sais pas si c'est lui qui a
commencé 7,7 ce comics là c'est
humoriste là mais déjà dont il utilise
ma photo comme photo de profil donc moi
je me réserve quand même le droit de
simples en de l'attaquer en justice pour
usurpation d'identité ça me fait sourire
mais je vais le faire comme ça parce que
je pense qu'il faut lui donner une
petite leçon et moi lui demander de
l'argent pour l'association que je
dirige mais aussi pour les ong la est
extrêmement sympa en plus il est très
drôle hein j'adore mois souligne amélie
parole mais la torre et il est très
drôle et voilà je suis sûr qu'il arrive
je suis sûr qu'il serait le premier à
donner d'argent pour l'association c'est
le fera je suis sûr mais on a pré voilà
il à lui a demandé hier déjà ça fait 20
ans qu'ils à peu près 24 heures il ya
toujours pas de réponse pour il va le
terrain à lui a demandé en commentaire
de dire bon vous plaisantez dessus c'est
bien amusez vous vous êtes français vous
êtes libre voilà mais nous voilà ce
qu'ont subi etc plutôt que de faire ça
comme ça demande un euro à chaque
personne qui commence à donner sur ce
lien le lien ci-dessous 0 nous la bonne
idée ça là sa réponse a été de mettre
une affiche de son de son prochain show
bon voilà c'est chacun ses valeurs moi
donc il n'ya pas de
moi j'ai simplement accueilli parce que
c'est une amie j'espère qu'elle ira bien
et surtout j'espère qu'elle pourra
retourner chez elle bien sûr parce que
c'est ça l'idée et il a le sait parce
qu'on en parle de temps en temps je n'en
suis pas certain voilà je n'en suis pas
certain j'espère que ça se passera bien
voilà je ne sais pas quels pays elle va
retrouver qu'elle apprécie si elle
rentre et c'est moi je lui ai aussi dit
que ma porte et est ouvert ma porte
personnel était ouverte à toute sa
famille et à tous ses amis peu importe
si on doit être une dizaine dedans c'est
pas le problème voilà on ne fera de la
place vous fera en fera on appelle ça il
ya une très grande solidarité qui s'est
mise en place au delà de l'association
d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup de voisins
d'amis qui viennent de même donné des
vêtements des matelas neuf sont posées
et c'est bon on a énormément de gens qui
viennent nous voir pour ça et vous avez
énormément de collecte qui sont faites
d'autres associations qui en a eu en
voilà bah des médicaments des vêtements
etc bon nous on travaille sur l'accueil
en tant qu elle soit centrale sur
laquelle dirigeantes d'associations
j'aurais été si je ne faisais pas moi
même bien sûr voilà